era reunidos en esta ocasión a pensar en
cómo salir mejores y no peores de esta
crisis inspiraba en su que predica y en
su ejemplo vengo a ratificar un
llamamiento al mundo entero a recrear un
multilateralismo basado en nuestra
solidaridad
no es tiempo de globalizar la
indiferencia sino de globalizar la
solidaridad en múltiples dimensiones
esta pandemia no se ha revelado frágiles
y ha recreado la necesidad de construir
puentes entre personas entre naciones y
entre regiones
si estamos siendo capaces de fabricar
respiradores artificiales uniendo piezas
y saberes de diferentes regiones del
planeta tenemos que ser capaces de soñar
y construir respiradores no artificiales
para el tiempo de la post pandemia
si estamos uniendo esfuerzos de médicos
investigadores inversionistas y sistemas
científicos de todo el planeta para
descubrir una vacuna que prevenga el
commit 19 tenemos que ser capaces de
soñar y construir una vacuna contra la
injusticia social la depredación
ambiental la discriminación en todas sus
formas
este espíritu solidario es el que mi
gobierno ha priorizado desde su llegada
porque de la pandemia al igual que de la
pobreza
nadie se salva solo
es por eso que desde los primeros
momentos de la pandemia la argentina
priorizó la salvaguarda de la vida y el
cuidado de los más vulnerables
implementando una serie de medidas de
emergencia que permitieron evitar el
colapso del sistema de salud y mitigar
las consecuencias inmediatas de la
pandemia
se brindó a alivio inmediato a las
familias ya las empresas mediante
múltiples medidas con un estado presente
y activo en este mismo espíritu de
solidaridad nosotros sostenemos que la
vacuna que se produzca para prevenir la
enfermedad que hoy padecemos tiene que
ser un bien público global accesible a
todas las naciones de una manera
equitativa
nos sumamos a las resoluciones adoptadas
en este sentido por esta asamblea
general y hemos puesto a disposición de
nuestras capacidades
hemos puesto a disposición nuestras
capacidades perdón para la investigación
y la producción de la vacuna
después se como objetivo de gobierno
volver a poner a la argentina de pie
pero juntos podemos volver a poner al
mundo de pie ello requiere que
reconozcamos la importancia del
equilibrio
el equilibrio es restablecer las
prioridades del sistema multilateral
empezando por los últimos para llegar a
todos
tenemos que ser arquitectos de una nueva
casa común ante la aparición de la
pandemia se planteó la necesidad de
reformar el consejo de seguridad de las
naciones unidas y hay acuerdo sobre
rehabilitar la organización mundial de
comercio se planteó también la crisis
del mecanismo de las instituciones de
bretton woods que habían demostrado
limitaciones para responder a las crisis
financieras del año 2008 y 2009
todos eslabones de la arquitectura
multilateral nacidas de la posguerra la
también la pandemia también ha puesto en
crisis las clásicas métricas para
determinar el acceso a los recursos para
el desarrollo indicadores utilizados
comúnmente para clasificar las
necesidades de los países como el
ingreso per cápita ya no dan cuenta de
las desigualdades y realidades diversas
que existen dentro de un mismo país
asimismo convertimos en invisible el
trabajo de millones de personas
mayoritariamente mujeres que aportan con
el trabajo doméstico y de cuidado no
remunerado
resulta indispensable también revela el
modo en que concebimos la cooperación
adoptando una perspectiva
multidimensional que vaya más allá del
ingreso per cápita para determinar
criterios de elegibilidad para recibir
ayuda
oficial al desarrollo
más del 60% de los pobres habitan en
países de renta media si no atendemos a
estos países en forma solidaria y
entendiendo que el verdadero progreso se
construye con todos adentro
difícilmente logremos realizar avances
decididos hacia la consecución de los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
todo lo anterior nos indica que resulta
imprescindible dinamizar las capacidades
de las naciones unidas- para dar
respuesta al mandato para el que fue
creada
necesitamos unas naciones unidas- 4.0
con sus valores fundacionales intactos y
con la lucidez para incorporar los
inmensos cambios tecnológicos en marcha
para hacerlos más humanos más
democráticos y más inclusivos
socialmente
todo esto marca la necesidad de una
profunda reflexión que trasciende la
respuesta dada a la pandemia
el camino de salida de la pandemia y
hacia los objetivos de la agenda 2030
requiere promover políticas económicas
industriales y sociales orientadas al
cambio estructural de nuestras economías
el compromiso con la agenda ambiental
requiere una importante provisión de
recursos financieros creación de
capacidades y transferencias de
tecnología por parte de los países
desarrollados a la luz de los principios
de responsabilidades comunes pero
diferenciadas
nuestro país está comprometido con una
agenda de transición justa hacia el
desarrollo integral y sostenible
transición justa refiere a la
gradualidad el esfuerzo de la
productividad y competitividad de la
economía y la creación de empleos
estamos firmemente convencidos de que es
necesario un compromiso colectivo para
lograr la pronta y efectiva
implementación del acuerdo de parís
nadie se salva solo en un planeta que se
incendia se inunda o se envenena
en este tormento solo contexto global el
endeudamiento externo tóxico es
responsable con fines especulativos
constituye otra ola de atraso y
desarrollo
la argentina logró sellar un importante
acuerdo con casi la totalidad de los
acreedores externos privados
convirtiéndose en uno de los países en
enfrentar el desafío de afrontar la
reestructuración de la deuda en el marco
de la pandemia
el pueblo de la comunidad internacional
que incluye a varios países aquí
presentes como el sector privado la
sociedad civil y la comunidad académica
internacional ha sido clave para
recuperar la sostenibilidad de la deuda
pública
las negociaciones con el fondo monetario
internacional
vamos a encarar las de la misma manera
de forma responsable siendo respetuosos
de los compromisos contraídos pero
evitando al mismo tiempo poner en riesgo
las condiciones que permitan la
reactivación económica y la construcción
de un sendero de desarrollo inclusivo y
sostenible
hace poco más de 5 años en días de
septiembre del 2015
esta asamblea general aprobó la
resolución 69/3 19 sobre principios
básicos de los procesos de
reestructuración de la deuda soberana el
posicionamiento de la asamblea sentó un
precedente para la gobernanza de las
finanzas internacionales y el
reconocimiento de los derechos
económicos soberanos frente a
comportamientos abusivos y exclusivos
todo ello con el objetivo de dar
racionalidad y previsibilidad a los
procesos de reestructuración de deudas
con base en la buena fe la transparencia
el trato equitativo la inmunidad
soberana de la jurisdicción y de
ejecución la legitimidad y
sostenibilidad y la reestructuración por
mayoría instamos a la comunidad
internacional a continuar buscando
nuevas alternativas multilaterales que
faciliten la reestructuración ordenada
de las deudas y permitan asegurar la
mayor disponibilidad de recursos para la
aplicación de políticas públicas para
enfrentar la pandemia y sostener el
crecimiento inclusivo
ningún país puede pagar su deuda a costa
de que su pueblo quede sin salud sin
educación sin seguridad o sin capacidad
de ingresar
también ese equilibrio priorizar los
derechos humanos por sobre todo lo demás
la promoción y protección de los
derechos humanos es de hecho una
política fundamental del estado
argentino desde 1983 esta decisión se ha
traducido en la ratificación y el
otorgamiento de rango constitucional a
todos los instrumentos internacionales
de derechos humanos vigentes y en
nuestra activa participación en el
sistema universal y regional las
banderas de memoria verdad y justicia
guían las instituciones de nuestra
democracia al igual que el respeto a la
diversidad y a la inclusión
el mundo post pandemia puede exacerbar
la graves crisis de refugiados y
desplazados que afronta el planeta y
nuestra región
también la respuesta debe ser la
promoción y garantía de los derechos
humanos de los migrantes como nunca
antes nuestra condición humana nos
demanda solidaridad no podemos quedar
pasivos frente a sanciones que suponen
bloqueos económicos que sólo asfixian a
los pueblos en medio de esta crisis
humanitaria
la lucha contra toda forma de
discriminación y el compromiso con los
derechos de las personas y grupos
vulnerables e históricamente
discriminados que es parte de esta
política del estado argentino que se
proyecta en las numerosas iniciativas
que la argentina apoya y lidera
la crisis global provocada por el commit
19 también ha puesto de manifiesto la
desigualdad de género
para nuestra sociedad el logro de la
igualdad sustantiva entre varones y
mujeres es una prioridad y un pilar
central de la democracia argentina mi
gobierno está comprometido con ello y
por eso por primera vez en la historia
hemos creado el ministerio de la mujer
género sin diversidad así como un
gabinete nacional para ser transversales
las políticas de género
nuestro gobierno decidió reforzar las
acciones y dispositivos nacionales de
atención a las mujeres que son víctimas
de violencia al tiempo que hemos
instrumentado un enfoque de género en
las medidas de protección social y
laboral y hemos promovido la
corresponsabilidad y una distribución
más justa de las tareas de cuidado
el compromiso es evidente argentina ha
sido clasificada en el ranking de la onu
como el país que más medidas con
perspectivas de género implementó
durante la pandemia
no quisiera dejar de ratificar que la
argentina condena al terrorismo en todas
sus formas y manifestaciones
y privilegia su tratamiento en el marco
de los foros multilaterales siempre en
el marco del imperio del estado de
derecho y el respeto a los derechos
humanos
a 26 años del atentado a la sede de la
amia quiero continuar la política
iniciado en este ámbito en año 2003 y
continuada posteriormente y requerir a
las autoridades la república islámica
dirán que cooperen con las autoridades
judiciales argentinas para avanzar en la
investigación de dicho atentado
también solicitamos a la comunidad
internacional cumplimentar las
solicitadas contenidas en las cédulas
rojas de interpol ante la eventual
presencia de un imputado en sus
territorios algo que la argentina jamás
dejó de reclamar
para terminar quiero reafirmar los
legítimos e imprescriptibles derechos de
soberanía de la república argentina
sobre las islas malvinas georgia del sur
sandwich al sur y los espacios marítimos
circundantes los cuales forman parte
integrante del territorio nacional de
argentina y que se encuentran ocupados
ilegalmente por el reino unido desde
hace ya más de 187 años
este año se cumplirán 55 años de la
resolución 2065 la primera adoptada por
esta organización relativa a la cuestión
de las islas malvinas que solicitó a la
argentina y al reino unido- mantener
negociaciones que permitiesen alcanzar
una solución pacífica y definitiva a
esta disputa de soberanía
ese pedido se ha mantenido vigente y ha
sido renovado en múltiples ocasiones más
recientemente con la luz tal con la
adopción por consenso de una nueva
resolución sobre la cuestión por parte
del comité especial de descolonización
el pasado 5 días del 5 de agosto
el reino unido- persiste en su actitud
de desoír el llamado a reanudar las
negociaciones respecto de la disputa
territorial y ha agravado la
controversia por los llamados a la
explotación ilegal y unilateral de los
recursos naturales renovables y no
renovables en el área acción contraria a
la resolución 31/49 de esta asamblea
también insisten con la injustificada y
desmedida presencia militar en las islas
que no hace más que traer tensión a una
región caracterizada por ser una zona de
paz y cooperación internacional
hemos solicitado al señor secretario
general que renueve sus esfuerzos en la
misión de buenos oficios que le fuera
encomendada por esta organización
confiamos en que esta misión pueda ser
de gran asistencia para que podamos dar
cumplimiento a los dispuestos por la
comunidad internacional
quisiera despedirme de esta honorable
asamblea haciendo un llamamiento para
que aprovechemos esta oportunidad
histórica de unirnos como sociedad para
hacer frente a una crisis sin
precedentes
la pandemia de coronavirus se ha llevado
la vida de más de un millón de personas
y está dejando secuelas dolorosas que se
manifiestan en mayor pobreza más hambre
más desigualdad poniendo de nuevo a
prueba todo
espero que la solidaridad el diálogo y
la cooperación entre naciones como
alguna vez supimos hacerlo sigan siendo
el camino para enfrentar los desafíos
que tenemos como humanidad muchas
gracias